[Musica]
benvenuti ad un nuovo episodio del
leccio con karim usa
oggi vi voglio parlare di una storia
d'amore una storia fatta di intrighi di
segreti misteriosi e di tradimenti
se non fosse che rimangono tutti in vita
o se ne dire shakespeariana una storia
come ce ne sono tante ma che tocca i
cuori di tutti noi
sto parlando di christian de sica e
massimo boldi e li ho fregati e penso
all udc so di chi sto parlando tutto 33
poeta che aveva la di cristian deville e
li so fare ancora randagia boldi de sica
la coppia che probabilmente ha fatto
guadagnare di più nell'intera storia
dell'industria cinematografica italiana
per decine di anni hanno sfornato film
su film che hanno fatto guadagnare
centinaia di milioni di euro in tutta
italia è proprio per questo la gente li
odia perché tutti siamo stati colpevoli
ma è compreso di aver insultato nel
corso degli anni le madri di tutti
quelli che hanno lavorato ai
cinepanettoni ma la gente soprattutto
internet spesso si dimentica che non è
sempre stato così abbiamo già parlato da
quando è nato internet tutti si sentono
in dovere di dire la propria opinione è
ok
solo che così mi vengono distrutte le
fondamenta delle informazioni base che
io ho costruito per una vita soprattutto
con gli artisti per esempio crescendo
tutti amavano vasco rossi
tutti ora guardi su internet e devo
diato tutti quelli che conoscevo e che
il che sentivo per strada in giro in
televisione adoravano e ascoltavano
ligabue
adesso tutti lauder su internet e nei
call back porca di una [ __ ] io li
adoravo io avevo tutti gli album e li
cantavo a memoria e con internet ho
scoperto che una delle band più odiate
dal mondo intero ma perché e questo
succede però anche per altri tipi di
artisti per esempio boldi de sica
forse non lo saprete o vi farà strada
che c'è stato un bel periodo storico del
cinema italiano in cui boni de sica
erano ovunque e venivano adorati da
chiunque con ragione secondo me ma
partiamo da un punto preciso e secondo
me quel punto è il film io peso il quale
non solo ha formato un nuovo tipo di
comicità cinematografica italiana ma
anche spedito nell'olimpo dei migliori
comici italiani circa gente come
christian de sica massimo boldi gerry
calà e ezio greggio e giustappunto mica
bau bau micio micio ma sono sicuro che
vi starete chiedendo una cosa
soprattutto i più giovani di voi si
staranno chiedendo ma quale generazione
di pokémon appartiene in questi gruppi è
ortaggi vostra me lo spiego subito uno
yuppie è un termine inglese che stava a
rappresentare un certo tipo ti giovane
erano quegli uomini d'affari intorno ai
30 anni legati fortemente all'economia
del momento quindi giravano con vestiti
di marca tutti perfettamente agghindati
con auto di lusso nei locali più belli
d'italia in mezzo alla milano da bere e
agli anni 80 è il portavoce protagonista
dello yuppismo in italia era proprio
l'avvocato agnelli che aveva un'immagine
ineccepibile i suoi vestiti perfetti e
l'immancabile orologio sopra la manica
della giacca
attenzione tutte le donne volevano stare
con loro tutti gli uomini volevano
essere loro in una sola parola
ostentazione e se tu vai a scavare per
bene si scopre che non gli hobby smo è
finito proprio quando è scoppiato
tangentopoli o cordate che coincidenza
ecco boldi de sica greggio e cala
rappresentavano questo tipo di ragazzi
in più pesa io quando avevo 16 17 anni
abbiamo appena iniziato a fare i video
ero uno di quelli che a denti stretti a
pugni chiusi andava sempre contro i
cinepanettoni cinepanettoni sono merda i
re dei cinepanettoni cia la merda del
cervello ma negli ultimi anni mi sono
fatto una specie di maratona dove sono
partito da yuppies in poi fino ai giorni
nostri a guardarmi tutte queste commedie
e se può notare perfettamente il punto
in cui smette di essere un film magari
di merda ma con un suo stile a diventare
soltanto feccia cristian è dato per fare
quel personaggio lì nei suoi film e lui
non ha bisogno di rappresentare lo
yuppie lui è uno yuppie seppe cosa per
piacere da me è morto louise carson
mostra grazia il personaggio gli è
calato talmente tanto bene addosso che
non ha mai smesso di farmi i suoi film è
sempre lo stesso personaggio è un gioco
anche a bacino che praticamente una
rischiate rimane fredda e io non ci
posso fare niente a me de sica mi fa
morire dal ridere
ed è una di quelle informazioni
personali di cui tu non puoi farne a
meno ma non puoi raccontarla nessuno e
quindi nei discorsi del dc9 christian de
sica me ha fatto sempre cagare che merda
morisse lui la sua famiglia
che schifo e finché farlo in rovinato in
cina però poi sai cosa fai
inizia a sudare inizia a starti stretta
la camicia e allora dicevo scusate devo
andare in bagno allora ti chiudi in
bagno a chiave tiri fuori il cellulare
inizia a guardare nel clip di christian
de sica perché non ne puoi fare a meno e
che ci dobbiamo fare ognuno ha i suoi
cazzi e va bene e christian de sica
l'abbiamo messo da parte
e bondi e poi è partito a fare lo stesso
identico personaggio anche lui faceva il
cumenda della milano da bere e poi non
si sa cosa sia successo tesi che è
rimasto col suo personaggio boldi no
sapete cos'è diventato bordi negli
ultimi dieci anni di film è diventato
una versione oscena di fantozzi
fateci caso prendete il fantozzi dei
tempi d'oro con tutta la sua comicità ma
anche con tutto il suo sottotesto triste
e tragico della vita italiana di quel
periodo e tutta la critica sociale
togliete tutta quella parte seria e
lasciate il fantozzi che si chiudeva le
dita nei cassetti e che faceva di versi
strani con la bocca quando veniva
colpito nei [ __ ] da qualcosa questo
è il personaggio che ha fatto boldi
negli ultimi dieci anni santo iddio ed e
secondo me questo il motivo per cui de
sica e boldi nel 2006 si sono divisi non
solo una carriera ma anche un'amicizia
finita
secondo me proprio per quel motivo
perché il personaggio di volti rispetto
a quello di de sica era diventato
talmente tanto una macchietta che non si
poteva più la mare via però noi che per
anni abbiamo seguito loro e ci siamo
portati nei nostri cuori
volevamo sapere come mai vi siete divisi
cosa è successo dopo tanti anni di
onorata carriera cosa cavolo è successo
qual è stata la scintilla che ha fatto
scoppiare tutto quanto è proprio nel
nell'anno della rottura de sica dice è
una decisione che ha preso massimo è
stato bellissimo il nostro percorso
insieme
ma credo che non lavorano più con lui
ecco queste sono parole che fanno male
qui che fanno male qui e de sica con
queste affermazioni ha lasciato i falli
in una bolla di dubbi ma giorni dopo
boldi risponde in una trasmissione
radiofonica dicendo abbiamo litigato per
una serie di motivi e tra questi c'è
anche quello dei soldi
cristian
deve 300 mila euro tante domande copri
come è possibile che christian de sica
debba massimo boldi 300mila euro e fatti
de sica risponde subito dicendo gli devo
300 mila euro
l'età avanza tornare con massimo sarebbe
una minestra riscaldata
come puoi dire così dopo una carriera è
un'amicizia durata decenni come puoi
dire una cosa del genere christian
finché qualche giorno fa non appare una
lettera una lettera scritta da boldi
indirizzata a de sica sulle pagine del
settimanale chi e piu che chi la domanda
è perché paul di scrivere una lettera
del genere su chi che non è che mi
stupisca più di tanto in realtà è anche
perché qualche mese fa in edicola ho
beccato la storia di maria de filippi a
fumetti su tv mia
non solo ma soprattutto a grande
richiesta e io mi chiedo perché dio non
mi abbia ancora fulminato
io vorrei leggervi la lettera di bondi
indirizzata a de sica io l'ho già letta
e nonostante sia morto letteralmente
dalle risate
questa non è una lettera bella è una
lettera tragica dove ci sono delle
informazioni molto personali di boldi
cose che sono successe con de sica e
raccontate su chi e soprattutto la
lettera della fine di un'amicizia
ricordatevi questo come vedete ho già
abbassato le luci e mi piacerebbe
mettere un sottofondo musicale che
sarebbe potuto essere la sonata al
chiaro di luna o ave maria invece vi
metto una chicca
non so se lo sapevate ma anni fa molti è
stato un talentuoso batterista e
probabilmente lo è ancora anni e anni fa
lui suonava in un gruppo capitanato da
claudio lippi pensa dove ti sto portando
con la merda e lasciamo perdere chiamato
la pattuglia azzurra quindi in
sottofondo alla lettura della lettera ci
sarà anima di gomma della pattuglia
azzurra
[Musica]
caro cristiane lo scorso natale ci siamo
fatti gli auguri erano poche parole ma
erano le nostre parole come sempre
sinceri io sto già piangendo mi spiace
vedere questo tuo lato debole che il
pubblico il tuo pubblico il nostro peter
non conosce la tua debolezza un nome
silvia tua moglie
vorrei ricordarvi che silvia la moglie
di feste de sica e silvia verdone la
sorella di carlo verdone che sia in di
schiato anche lui in questo marasma non
lo sappiamo
lei la tua gente che decide che
programma la tua vita da sempre anzi da
quando ha iniziato ad avere successo
e allora vedi che bondi sta rosicando e
allora un motivo c'è se si sono separati
a ecco oggi è passato più di un quarto
di secolo è tra noi che cosa resta solo
qualche messaggino
per l'amor del signore non dica mai più
messaggino mi raccomando perché mi fa
sentire molto più giovane schifoso del
previsto che raccomando ricordo quando
hai iniziato a lamentarsi della gabbia
in cui vive lì in cui ti avevano
rinchiuso odiavi le restrizioni la tua
generosità a un certo punto ha
conosciuto brutto stop ci hanno bloccato
silvia ti affermato diceva che eri uno
spendaccione e ti ha messo a paghetta
cerami in bacino de sica la paghetta
mi immagino che come un ragazzino di 12
anni che non può permettersi una cosa
volava a pregare la madre dicendo silvia
amore che hanno visto una cosa che
sarebbe molto bene sul nostro salotto
tanti prego l'ultimo regalo me lo hai
fatto a natale da giuro che ci gioco
tutti i giorni ti prego oggi a chi mi
ribello che christian e silvia non sono
venuti nemmeno al funerale di marisa mia
moglie la loro amica in giro giovani e
non mi chiedono quando tornate insieme
ecco signor molli quando capita questa
cosa mi raccomando faccio una foto chi
le ha chiesto questa speranza ta e mele
di perché voglio vederli in faccia
andare contro
il volere di dio che ci abiti o dimmi tu
o ditemi voi lo vedo come un piccato
cara silvia sappia una cosa mi manchi
anche tu mi mancano i tuoi consigli
sempre diretti e determinati mi manca
parlare con te di marisa mi mancano i
nostri ricordi
mi mancate tu e christian amici miei
vi voglio bene vostro massimo che non ha
commesso alcun peccato dunque questa
lettera per quanto ilare da una parte e
molto molto tragica dall'altra mi ha
fatto ricordare di una cosa di cui io
stesso mi lamento spesso e volentieri
cioè di voi della gente che guarda i
video che spesso si dimentica che c'è
una persona dietro lo schermo
l'avrete già sentito mille volte ma è
giusto ricordarlo ogni tanto che molto
spesso quello che ci succede intorno
nella nostra vita di tutti i giorni si
riflette poi nella qualità dei video e
ci dimentichiamo spesso che dietro i
poveri boni de sica che vengono
costantemente bombardati di insulti
minacce di morte gente che gli vuole
investire gente che gli vuole picchiare
con un martello molto forte sui denti
proprio per chetare singolarmente ogni
singolo dente staccarlo dalla bocca e
poi strappargli le lingue con delle
cesoie giganti
dietro ci sono delle persone e che
questa storia questa fine di un'amicizia
che io ho un pochino bellamente preso
per il culo e comunque la cosa che si
riflette sulla vita di entrambi e quindi
io vorrei dire una cosa christian e
massimo mi piacerebbe veramente vedere
un ultimo film fatto da voi insieme e
questo film si è fatto come si deve
potrebbe funzionare su più livelli
potrebbe riportare indietro nel tempo i
fan che ancora adesso vi apprezzano e
potrebbe stupire
quelli che invece mi insultano da anni
grazie mille ci vediamo ad un prossimo
video
è meglio
siate
un'occasione di gravissima ciò che vedo
anche se comunque toccante bravo